[Music]
homie look what I become
some protein all right so uh episode 194
with uh Lieutenant Colonel Stewart
scheller which is a very interesting
story by the way folks we've been gone
for about a week on YouTube we just
found out this morning we can come back
on live we back we're gonna do this on
Vimeo but it's good to be on with you
guys we got a like I said a special
guest with a special story who's got a
lot of Courage who stood up a lot of
people were talking about it this man
actually put his career on the line and
made a decision and we got a lot of
things to talk to him about a lot of
current events as well as some decisions
that he made so with that being said
thank you so much for being a guest on
the podcast thanks for having me guys
excited to be here yeah so you know for
for folks who don't know you obviously
I've seen you
in uniform when your story went viral
when you were being talked about all
over the place when you made some
comments uh against uh your leadership
for the way they as you know they left
Afghanistan and you wanted
accountability you came out you talked
about it you got that one comment made
by somebody you respected who
step away and then 17 years later you
make the video and you resign so why
don't you tell us a little bit about how
that whole thing came about and then
we'll go from there yeah so I was a
17-year infantry officer in the Marine
Corps Iraq Afghanistan commanded at the
platoon company Battalion level got a
masters in military science and the
Afghanistan evacuation was the straw
that broke the camel's back for me it
was just there's no better list of
mistakes that were made by senior
military leaders and I was at a place in
my career where I knew Not only would no
one take accountability but that the the
military's figured out how to weaponize
the media and so they would spin it as a
victory or is it as a success and so I
made a video where I asked for
accountability my senior military
leaders and then I got fired and it
escalated ultimately culminating with me
doing some jail time
um pleading out at a court martial and
exiting the Marine Corps shorted my
retirement so 17 years benefits I know
sometimes if they ask people to leave at
15 they'll give them benefits but this
is not the case you were three years
away from getting the I think it ended
up costing you what around two million
dollars yeah so it's it's about uh 4 000
a month for the rest of my life so yeah
if I live till 85 it could even be more
than 2 million right so somebody can do
the math on that I'm 41. but basically I
gave up 4 000 a month for for the rest
of my life when when you were when you
were about to come out and say what you
were gonna say uh there was a question
that was asked that said what what do
you want to get accomplished right I
think it was that question who you're
not going to come out without having
processing it with other people it's not
like you're a private or an E4 or you're
you're an officer Lieutenant Colonel 05
it's not like it's just somebody who's
emotional irrational coming out had a
couple drinks I'm going to come out and
make the comments you're a Family Guy
you got a masters you're somebody that's
educated you're somebody that's smart so
before coming out you knew you had to
know that if you were to say something
like that it's gonna hurt your 17-year
career what was the Tipping Point for
you to say screw it I'm going to make
this decision I'm going to go out and
call them out
you know it wasn't thought out before
that day but if you go back and watch
the video I I stated that I knew I was
risking my retirement and my job so I
had obviously thought through it but
there just comes a point where your
individual values come in conflict with
the system and this happens actually
quite frequently but for me this was one
of those moments where it was so big
that I just felt like the service
members deserved a leader to give timely
assessment of failure and that my
individual advancement wasn't as
important as the betterment of the
institution so I joined the military to
leave a better America for my children
not to have a secure stability in
retirement and this was one of those
moments where it was like if it's not me
then who if not now then when and I just
decided that it was more important it
was born out of love for the military
for love of the organization and love of
the Marines that I felt like they
deserved a leader to address what was
really happening I think that part's
obvious that it came from a place of
being a True Believer of I don't think
it was coming from a place of wanting to
get eyeballs or anything like that I
firmly believe you came from a place of
being a True Believer to talk about it
but do you think what you wanted to
accomplish got accomplished or do you
think it's kind of an event that's been
forgotten about and the likelihood of us
holding those leaders accountable is
slim to none
well so the question's complicated
because people ask it all the time you
know did you accomplish what you wanted
to accomplish first of all we didn't get
in the situation overnight we're not
going to get out of it overnight and
it's not going to be just like a binary
we fix it or we didn't fix it it's a
complicated problem I do think that
conversations have been started but
ultimately you know am I able to
influence the change it doesn't just
stop with the statements I made you know
I wrote a book The to double down on on
that story and then it's really what can
I do in you know whether it's the
political Arena the entrepreneur Arena
the influencing of other people you know
this is a it's got to be like a lifetime
Endeavor it can't just be one event so
I'm still dedicated to it you know here
I am in Southern Florida doing a tour
talking to people I've got two more
events stacked up today and so I've been
very busy since I got out I'm committed
to it can I say definitively that it
will or won't change I just think it's
it's a tough uh question to answer the
book is crisis of command which just
came out September 6th how we lost trust
and confidence in American generals and
politicians when you were calling out
the leaders you know you know specific
leaders that you could have said you
know that person had responsibility in
this because there's a lot of people
that you during that time it was it's
Biden's fault how can you just pull it
in come out and you know it's it's
president's fault he's the
commander-in-chief he's the one that
screwed up here well no it's the
General's fault the general should have
given a better report no it is Biden's
fault no it's the people in the you know
who were actually there that didn't
properly report or no it's the prior
Administration everybody blames
everybody right
for from your perspective from your
point of view as an o5 who was in it who
knows the climate who knows how not to
leave who knows that others are talking
about us regularly everybody knows we're
eventually leaving Afghanistan who does
the buck stop with you know if you have
to say this person first then this
person then that person who would those
names be
yeah so I absolutely think President
Biden made some bad decisions but
when I went through my ordeal I never
actually used the word president use the
word Biden and every headline you read
about me said Lieutenant Colonel
scheller criticizes President Biden's
botched Afghanistan withdrawal never
used President Biden's name my wrath
during my ordeal was on the military
professionals and so where we're losing
Wars right now politicians are outlining
objectives so it's political objectives
that we're using violence to try to
compel an enemy to do something and
right now our general officers are not
being held accountable to that and
there's a lot of reasons why one of the
biggest ones is they rotate out every
two years and you can't accomplish the
goals within the time frame of their
little tours and so it's like well if
none of us are accountable
um you know if one of us can't see it
from start to end then no one's really
accountable and so my position was in
April and I can go through the list real
quick in April 1 2021 President Biden
ordered a withdrawal of military forces
from Afghanistan and the theater
Commander at the time was a guy named
General McKenzie my opinion is General
McKenzie should have pushed back and and
not allowed that to happen now General
McKenzie and his Congressional testimony
has said that he disagreed with the
president's order and he said as much
through secretary Austin but the
president said no this is what you're
going to do so there's a moral case
study right there so people often say
well if you're the general you have to
follow the orders well there's
historical case studies if you go back
to Carter's presidency there was a guy
named singlob
s-i-n-g-l-a-u-b and he was the commander
of all forces in Korea and it's like the
same situation Carter and Biden a lot of
similarities and Carter said I want you
to pull all American forces out of Korea
and sing Labs like if you do that the
Koreans will all go to war that whole
Korean War we had it'll all be for
naught and Carter said I heard you out
but this is what we're doing and then
singlob went public with this
disagreement with Carter and he
ultimately changed the course of those
events right so we don't make generals
like that anymore so Mackenzie could
have done that he chose not to right
secondly we not only are we evacuating
military forces before we evacuate
American citizens no-brainer but we
decide to do it from April to September
anyone that served in Afghanistan knows
that Taliban hides in the mountains in
the winter that's why we have what we
call a Spring fighting season so we
could have conducted the withdrawal from
October to March and been completely
uncontested but we did it in the peak
fighting season because the pr date of
September 11th was more important than
American lives and American Treasures so
there's like two huge mistakes that I
saw play out real time as I'm watching
this
and then the third week so this is
information that I've got later the
military investigation that was
presented to Biden I think the guy the
reporter's name was like Lester Holt
Luke Holt something like that yeah so he
asked President Biden hey the military
investigation what do you think about it
President Biden's that I reject it and
so then he came back and he tried to ask
like an intelligent follow-up question
like what parts do you disagree with and
he just said again I reject it and
that's the only thing we've got from the
president on that investigation well
that investigation was sent to me by a
disgruntled staff officer and in the
investigation it lays out that General
McKenzie's planner so when he was doing
the withdrawal starting one April he
assigned a separate General officer to
plan the evacuation so in DC they're
planning they be prepared to evacuation
separate Mission those planners planned
on using Bagram all the way until the
third week of June when unexpectedly
then General McKenzie ordered them to
pull Bagram off the off the table Bagram
was the key piece of train that we
needed the planners even when you read
the investigation don't understand why
he made that decision General McKenzie
and his Congressional testimony later
said because 650 troops wasn't enough to
hold the embassy and the H Kaya Airfield
right next to the Embassy and so he
decided to pull off pogram well so the
next week we we abandoned Bagram a month
later 10 August the Taliban walks in
finds 7 000 prisoners I mean that's more
than we responded to in the entire Kabul
disaster and that's not even counting
the Taliban Force right so then those
seven thousand all the Taliban walk up
to Kabul now it's 15 August this is when
General McKenzie realizes his plan is
falling apart he throws 5 000 troops in
addition to the 650 at Kabul so two
Marine battalions in the 82nd they clash
with the Taliban the Marines have
confirmed now that they killed you know
five to six at least Taliban fighters
that's never reported
then that same day General McKenzie
orders them to stand post with the
people they just killed calls them a
critical external partner they obviously
allow the suicide bomber to go through
the checkpoint probably came from the
prison kills the 13 service members
injures 20 more kills hundreds of Afghan
civilians in the gate in response we
conduct a drone strike kill nothing but
women and children and then we stand
there and called an overwhelming success
I mean there is no better list of just
poor decisions that were made and so
yeah the junior enlisted service member
standing on the wall grabbing babies
over barbed wire is doing everything can
he's not thinking about politics and I
got all that but no one is going back
and saying hey the decisions that were
made between the National Security
Council and the four-star general put
our service members in a terrible
position and there was plenty of
off-ramps and preventable ways to do
this better
such as
well I mean you could just go through it
obviously and the reason why I asked
this is the following here's here's what
I ask let's just say all of a sudden
you know in business somebody's making a
bad decision at the top right and it's a
big business not a small business
Afghanistan is not a small business it's
a big business meaning we put a lot of
money into it we didn't put 10 million
100 million a billion dollars we put
real money into Afghanistan some are
saying the trillion some are saying
three trillion that's a lot of money
that we put into this thing that's a big
investment
so when something like that happens and
people are fully vested their lives
their friends have died they've seen
crisis they've seen issues you've
witnessed stuff that stuff's going to be
with you until they do that you die you
can't get that out of you right so
you're emotionally vested you're TR to
an average person's like what are you
guys complaining about it's just we're
out it's done it's over why are you
still complaining about it what are you
talking about you weren't there seeing
what's a sacrifice we were paying
was there was there hardcore arguments
on the back end this agreements fight
saying what the hell are we doing who's
agreeing to this was there anybody
courageous enough to go to McKinsey and
say why are you making this decision why
are we going were there any stories like
that that we're not aware of no not that
I know of how is that even possible
that's exactly right I mean that's why I
made the video because I felt exactly
what we're talking about now no one's
having these conversations and it's
crazy it really it was just quite I
couldn't fathom the the list of
decisions that were made and you know
I've had some staff officers that wrote
some of the operational plans and and
they told me that Bagram was always part
of the plans but the National Security
Council rejected it right and so you
know they're not all dumb people but
it's just the way these decisions were
made without pushback was really my
whole contention from that first video
it's okay so we we've had multiple
people that have talked about how
different we could have done it you gave
one of them we could have waited a
little bit because the season would have
been better if we would have gone
October to March instead of you know
because they're trained for that uh you
know but they wanted to do a PR stunt
because of 911 so they didn't want to
wait that long they wanted to get it
done what other things could we have
done differently well the the no-brainer
is we should have just held on to Bagram
and maintained air support within the
country I mean for for decades that
would have been so easy to do that's
what we still do in Korea and we've got
hundreds of thousands still across
Europe from World War II I mean that
that was the no-brainer with a thousand
people you could have held Bagram and
you could have had this huge air
presence and that's what we've been
doing for the last five years I mean
people don't really like it's not like
the wars of 2009 through 12. I mean
really for the last five years all we've
done is provide air support uh for our
Afghan National partners and so the
decision to pull that I mean I just it
was hard for me to wrap my brain around
it Stu most of us saw this clip yeah
this clip went viral you know to and
then you hear people saying well you
know it's not really this it's Photoshop
it's it's from another time it's this
it's Dad you guys don't know what you're
talking about why are you guys spreading
conspiracy theories what what can you
tell us from personal experience of what
this this image this picture this video
that we all saw represents yeah I mean
that's real
um some of those Pilots so imagine a 03
uh a mid-20s Air Force pilot in that
plane right now and he has to make
decisions of whether he's going to kill
three yeah young guys right so like
that's not talked about think about the
20 year old pilot that has to make
decisions to either stop the plane
or keep driving and kill potentially all
those people holding onto the plane and
they were afraid that if they stopped
the plane the plane was going to get
overrun and destroyed and so that poor
guy had to make the decision to
essentially kill people to take off and
who were those people what were they
looking to do so this is the um H Kaya
Airfield so this is we made the decision
to to basically drop down to two two
spots the embassy in h Kaya Airfield and
then eventually we evacuated the embassy
and now we're just operating out of this
place this place was just not easily
defended it had like 13 14 checkpoints
and what happened was on 15 August when
the Taliban rolled up they pushed all of
the civilians into the Airfield and kind
of used them as cover when they were
getting into firefights and so when they
pushed all the civilians on the Airfield
this is right when the Americans were
also responding didn't have their act
together this was the chaos that ensued
can I let me ask you a question well
number one generally thank you for your
service I know a lot of people just kind
of say that but generally
um I'm getting this sense of deep deep
somberness and mindfulness from you so I
I I'm going to ask you a personal
question right now I'm asking Stu a
question not Lieutenant Colonel Stuart
shell appreciate it if you don't mind
yes I'm asking Stu like how are you
feeling right now are you are you angry
are you distraught are you fired up are
you confident are you at peace like
genuinely Stu how are you feeling
you know it's emotions are day to day
right
um genuinely right now I'm kind of tired
because I had to get up at 5am to drive
over here but
um yeah your question is my headspace
and I'll tell you when I wrote the book
and then you have to like re-read the
book a hundred times for editing
purposes that was like physically
draining to me to the point where when I
like read it for the the umpteenth time
at the end of April I literally couldn't
read it again and I didn't read it until
it came out in September because it just
took such a spiritual physical mental
toll and um yeah and so there's a lot of
unknown I've always been I knew what was
next you know high school then I'm gonna
go to college once I go to college I'm
going to join the Marine Corps and then
I'm in the Marine Corps you know I'm
going to go to retirement and like right
now there isn't a plan and I'm trying to
be comfortable with just
kind of trying to see where this path
leads me and so that also kind of takes
a toll and then traveling you know I've
I've been just in the last couple weeks
I was in Texas and then Southern
California then after this I'm going to
Nashville and then to Vegas you know and
so that also can be draining
um but I feel like I'm kind of Guided by
a bigger purpose and you know I like
being busy and so I guess that's a lot
of words to say I don't know man it's
day to day what is your you said you've
been in the military 17 years yeah all
right you got in at 0-4
I yeah I I put in the paperwork in a
four I started boot camp January five
okay so uh and you got out less than a
year ago give or take Christmas Eve last
year okay so you've been a civilian for
less than 12 months that's right
um you talked about a bigger purpose now
you you're kind of
you know uh you know Moses and the
desert lost wandering basically right
now not to get too biblical but what is
your deeper sense of purpose now that
you're a civilian well the natural path
or like the the way the current is
taking me is towards politics but the
truth is I don't know if I want to be a
politician the only thing that kind of
outweighs that is I have a huge disdain
for the current politicians right so
it's like do I want to go and try and do
that
um because it's just I the last six
months I've been supporting different
candidates and so I've kind of gotten a
PhD in politics and how campaigns work
how Town Halls work blah blah blah and
so I I have a deeper understanding of it
but it's just a it's a ruthless game and
I think I would be happier just to you
know being a farmer to be quite honest
with you reading and writing but at the
same time when I'm probably most
passionate about is leaving a better
America for my children and if I don't
see the leadership qualities and the
people that are Representatives that may
compel me to go do that and so that's
kind of the internal struggle right now
you said you're tired uh at any point
you just you said being a farmer do you
want to just take a year and just chill
seriously yeah
um we all saw a gladiator right yeah and
like and just he wants to kind of just
that's right harvest the you know his
land and just touch the land not fight
anymore yeah you're still fighting but
in a different uh Arena now you're 100
right
um yeah absolutely that calls to me I I
don't know
right now the the drawback to waiting so
when I was uh going through everything I
went through I'll give you an example of
the the risk to waiting so the nrcc the
way politics work
the for congress the release the
Republican Party divides the United
States up into five regions and then
each one of those five people find
candidates for the for congress so this
guy came down and wanted me to run out
of Congress for the the GOP in North
Carolina he came and he sought me out
like uh September October of 21.
and I I essentially told him no but his
argument was the longer you wait uh you
know the notoriety the name brand the
ability to influence degrades and I was
like well that's fine but I'm just not
mentally I don't have the headspace I'm
you know my I'm going through a divorce
my stuff's in storage I don't know where
I'm gonna be in six months like I can't
do it right and and so now you know fast
forward I've got a place where all my
stuff's out of storage my divorce is
finalized I'm in a good place with her
the kids and I've wrote a book so I kind
of got that story out there it's a
little bit better but at the same time
to your point you know maybe now it's
time to step back or is it you know you
weigh that against you know exploit the
opportunities as you have them now don't
stop and so I don't know I don't think
there's a right or wrong answer I think
it's just something that I got to figure
out on my own but there's there's cost
to both I gotta I want to do this
because when you have something like
this experience that you have it's
important for us to know when we're
we're having currently Ukraine and
Russia going on we have Taiwan and China
going on we have these types of issues
that's going on we have Iran going on
right now with the people protesting
we've got a lot of stuff going on right
now we have a an Elon Musk who if you
want to pull up his tweet I'll just read
it to
uh read it to you what Elon Musk just
recently said I think we all saw it it
was yesterday but I'll just give the
whole context so people know just pull
up the tweets so we can have it
um let me see here if I have it okay so
Elon Musk warned civilization is over if
Ukraine doesn't give in to Russia okay
self-proclaimed political expert Elon
Musk obviously that comment means they
like him a lot has issued a stark
warning to Ukraine as Russia's Invasion
countries continues using Twitter the
platform he is likely to soon own and
control the world's richest man made a
number of eyebrow raising predictions
for eventualities regarding the outcome
of Russia's invasion of Ukraine if
Russia is faced with the choice of
losing Crimea or using Battlefield nukes
they will choose the latter the SpaceX
and Tesla Co tweeted the West has
already sanctioned cut off Russia in
every possible way
so what more do they have left to lose
if we nuke Russia back they will nuke us
and then we have world war three in
short musk is arguing that Ukraine
should
give in to Russia's demand or else a
highly controversial perspective that
has already landed him in hot water
recently last week he announced SpaceX
will no longer Supply starlink Internet
satellite Tech to Ukraine a decision he
reversed two days later they're not
saying why
one of their diplomats one of their
leaders told him to go f off that's why
he just canceled it but when when you
hear you know the experience and the
lack of proper decision making in
Afghanistan that you second guessed and
a lot of people also thinking yes you're
not alone there
and then we have this going on right now
where a guy like Elon Musk is commenting
how do you what do you think about what
Elon said and what do you think about
the way we've been handling Russia and
Ukraine
yeah so two very different questions so
first of all Crimea I mean Russia
annexed that way before the current
conflict that we're having here so I
think musses comments was a very annexed
Crimea
just acknowledge give them that um but
then there's still a whole bunch of
contested area right now in the Eastern
portion of Ukraine and so ultimately
what musk is advocating for is some
concessions by Ukraine and you know the
ukrainians are been operating the way
they have for the last 60ish years and
and they don't want to go back to
russia-controlled territory I don't know
it's complicated so I would say my
opinion is that the United States a lot
of times can't get out of its own way
and makes matters worse and so I'm not
sure that the
billions and billions of dollars that
we've given Ukraine was it the best
return on investment I think in a lot of
ways it probably cripples our European
allies who should be doing the same
thing I mean there's no better example
of a pacified culture than the Germans
the Germans are right there and should
really in my opinion be doing a lot more
How This Ends I'm not sure I think
people are getting a little too
hysterical about Vladimir Putin not
being a rational human being I I I don't
know if I agree with that assessment I
understand why he did what he did with
the advancement of NATO and but I do
believe it was a strategic mistake I do
believe he has old kbg thinking
um KGB excuse me and so you know his old
style of thinking is more land equals
more power and that's just not true in
today's world today it's controlling the
beliefs of the people is the ultimate
power and if by going from more land he
polarizes all the beliefs of the people
he's actually degraded a lot of his
power I mean look no further than Sweden
and Norway to look at his strategic
failures so really what we're arguing
about is some border region areas and I
don't know how that will play out but
I'm I'm not convinced that Vladimir
Putin is not rational and I'm also not
convinced that we should be giving as
much money to Ukraine as we are what's
the likelihood you think of this thing
getting ugly the way Elon says if we
make a couple bad moves this guy goes
first
we retaliated can turn into a world war
three what's the likelihood of that I
think it comes back to the the beliefs
of the people and so I think people in
America often want to project Russians
as these evil people Russians are you
know
very much like us white Christian
European type people like if you
actually hang out with a Russian they
they are they are very kind to Americans
and like Americans right if I went into
a Muslim country like Iran uh they would
not be as kind and they would have a
different belief system same thing with
the Chinese and so
I'm I guess I'm just not convinced that
the Russian people are gonna allow it to
happen but you know crazier things have
happened is it a threat that we should
be worried about absolutely but Elon
Musk uh projecting that Vladimir Putin
is completely irrational therefore we
must concede certain things I think is
maybe a stretch did you hear the rumor
that came out Tyler last week that
they're saying musk had a conversation
with Putin
I've heard that briefly did you hear
about that this last week away Elon Musk
had a conversation with Putin you know
an article saying did Elon Musk speak
with Vladimir Putin I don't know if uh
can you zoom in a little bit
um he's not repeating and Putin talking
point he's a he's a Putin asset because
the guy doesn't want to do anything to
piss off let me read this story from
1945 that just came out a couple days
ago Biden's Ukraine strategy could start
a nuclear war with Russia what too many
of our current leaders and enthusiastic
in Washington Hawks uh somehow failed to
recognize however is that unlike all our
military opponents of the past several
decades Russia's possession of nuclear
weapons means they can in a moment of
desperation of fear initiate a nuclear
war that could quite literally wipe the
United States out of existence obviously
that's hard
exaggeration but you know this is what
the writer is saying this should not
this should not be hard to understand if
the U.S and NATO finally provide enough
Firepower intelligence and training to
Ukrainian troops
that will enable them to physically
Drive Russian forces completely out of
Ukraine territories especially the
highly charged emotional areas of
donbass and Crimea Putin will be forced
into a corner where he has to choose
between allowing his entire force to be
completely defeated or escalate to use
of nuclear weapons what do you think
about what this article says
yeah I mean that's a that's a theory I I
I'm obviously not Vladimir Putin but I
don't know if I agree there's a way I
think for him to save face uh without
giving him all of the donbass area I
mean I'm not a geography major I've
looked at it on a map seems to be a
pretty big area I mean he already has
Crimea and I think quite honestly we've
already defeated him strategically like
even if he comes out of this with parts
of the donbass
don't know if he sees it as a victory so
like let's define that what is Victory
and what is complete defeat for him I
mean I don't know I I would submit
holding on to Crimea uh might not be a
complete defeat and there's probably
ways where we could come to the table
and make it not look like he completely
got defeated Maybe I'm Wrong
yeah I think that's the that's the real
question right yeah exactly what do you
do for him to save face because this is
not a regular guy that's you know he's
go he cannot be publicly offended yeah
and and that's what it's looking like
Tom history you've been you you followed
stories like this for a while how do you
what do you think is the proper way to
do something here where at least you you
please him but also at the same time
you're not doing something where you're
giving him everything he wants well I
think there's a lot of examples of this
that happen in the the resolutions of
the Arab Israeli Wars when you go back
and take a look like when Egypt came
across to us canal and Opera and then
occupied West Bank and remember what
happened was the Israelis pushed them
all the way back into the canal over the
canal and then took part of Egypt's land
on the other side and what you had to do
here is Israel is like I'm not giving
back the land on the other side of the
canal because now I have a buffer
against a known demonstrated aggressor
and so I'm going to extend the buffer
here and there's negotiations that had
to take place to make it literally a
demilitarized zone that Israel only
would accept policing that was 100
demilitarized by Egyptian forces and you
had to give Anwar Sadat even though he
was the aggressor a face saving
otherwise the people these Egyptian
people that just at their core of their
heart hate Israel you know we're not
going to be happy and they're going to
be rioting so you had to balance both
things for the ego of the leader as well
as the response to the people and I
think that's exactly the delicate thing
that had to happen here and the West had
to whisper to Israel and say listen you
took it back fair and square they came
across and you literally kicked the crap
out of them for seven days with U.S
equipment uh you're nodding you know the
history I do and then they head back and
they said okay we're going to come back
across but this will now be a completely
demilitarized zone there can be no
Egyptians that are armed in the area but
they can police it up to the old border
so the old Border was restored but
without presence of any military assets
which is what the only thing that the
Israelis would allow there can be no
military assets there because you've
demonstrated what you do with them and
so it saved face for Sadat it saved the
people being the the militant part of
the people from being an open conflict
the way they are constantly now it you
know on the other side of Jerusalem
where you have the three territories
that are never at peace and I think
that's exactly what has to happen here A
A an international Diplomat has to step
up find a way for him to save face maybe
let him keep Crimea and then pull back
on this because you've got you've got
this leader and it's happened before in
history we have rational people around
the world can come together to make to
to D to defuse what could be a second
bomb can I ask a question historically
what have been moments where a person
who played a role of a diplomat or
somebody that just was a unifier that
held a meeting between uh in the middle
of war that held a meeting between two
of the hated leaders or presidents or
prime ministers come together
historically how often has it happened
you think of people like Kissinger you
know who was a who was U.S but he was
seen as this he was really seen as a as
a old school you know ambassadorial
light touch Diplomat he was our guy and
he was U.S but he was able to he was
able to negotiate who's that guy today
with soft skills that can have these
types of conversations I think you go
back I I don't know well today I don't
know well two a couple different points
I'm gonna go blinking is not not talking
about well the first thing that comes to
mind was Clinton sitting down with
Yasser arafah and the attack Rabin
Israel PLO uh these days uh former
governor of New Mexico Bill Richardson
he's kind of sent all around the world
to get hostage out of uh enemy countries
um but to Tom's Point uh not to deviate
I don't know if you guys saw um on Bill
Maher this weekend they had uh Bibi
Netanyahu the former prime minister of
Israel you've spent some time in the
Israeli Lebanon conflict clicked in mid
2000s
the My ultimate question to Tom is that
example that you gave of the Suez Canal
and the Sinai Peninsula of Israel and
Egypt it's actually a great example the
only difference is now this guy's got
nukes and Putin has a much much much
bigger ego questionably a fragile more
fragile Eagle than
um Anwar Sadat so how do you grapple
with the fact that he's as he's such a
large World presence social media is so
much more Amplified everyone's eyeballs
on Ukraine versus an Egypt situation
before social media and he's got nukes
so yeah is it really a fair analogy I
think the human side of it is identical
just the tools and consequences are
worse because the tools are bigger but
the human side of it is the same and I I
also go back and I give credit to Jimmy
Carter and the Camp David Peace Accords
and I believe his guy was the big new
Brzezinski Mika brzezinski's Dad yes
right zinski yep I think he was our guy
that yes that broke her big time Big
Time at that who didn't need newspaper
headlines didn't want a book deal but he
quietly made it happen
um and I think to your question Pat
that's the kind of guy we need right now
I have two points I want to make on this
so first I've been holding on to this
Sadat comment I think Sadat and Putin
it's I understand the point you're
making but Sadat literally just wanted
to cross the Suez as like a a show of
force I don't think he ever wanted to
gain territory he just wanted to show
the Muslim world that he could cross the
Suez and then literally as Israel was
beating them back
he was declaring Victory because it was
more of a show whereas Putin I think you
know you wants to use violence and gain
territory so I've been sitting here
thinking you know how could we you know
give on this so Elon musk's
recommendation is strictly land-based
you know concessions of land literally
the reason what is driving Putin is not
uh maniacal Madness it's because he sees
natives expansion as a threat so if if
the West is going to concede something I
think the Don bass and the Crimea is
much less important than you know the
threat that NATO poses to Putin so quite
honestly you know if the United States
wanted to to end this war right now they
could say hey United States is pulling
out of NATO we're going to take all
those forces put them on our own
Southern border you guys figure it out
Putin says I'm okay with that and he
goes back to Russia I mean you could
solve that with something like that but
the problem is
so many people are invested in NATO that
that would also be a hard sell but that
would be a way you could de-escalate it
do you not think that it's vital for the
United States to be a major part of NATO
I think I would pull out of NATO
completely I think now do I think a
strong presence in the global Arena
establishes order yes do I think that
America has set the world tone for the
last century yes do I think NATO has
extremely crippled our European allies
yes and so why crippled be just the
budget is probably the biggest one right
if we weren't there providing as you
know 80 percent of the budget yeah then
they would be forced to spend more this
was essentially Trump's argument for
years yes
exactly pay your bill yeah pay your bill
but Trump was just advocating for them
to pay their three percent right right
and they weren't even doing that I don't
think Trump went far enough and quite
honestly with you know everyone can't
figure out how to to fix our Southern
border you don't even need to build a
wall just take all those NATO forces
that are across Europe and put them on
our Southern border and I could solve
the problem in a month like but that's
what we do it's not even just around
Europe I mean how many bases does the
United States have all over the world
800 something bases we've covered this
whereas like China has one and Djibouti
uh you've been to Djibouti it's the
worst place in the world really yeah it
is
um I'm not going there with you uh do
you think we need 800 bases all over the
world you know uh the number the
frequency of bases that had to take a
look at because there are like Djibouti
for example is where we fly all our uas
uh off of the the you know all those
contested areas and so there is some
strategic importance to some of them
um but yeah to your point I think we
have maybe scattered ourselves a little
thin and it's like one of those things
that once you get a base like just use
Djibouti for example all right we need
100 service members well those 100
service members need 50 people to run
the chow hall all right well those 50
people that run the chow hall also need
another 100 people to service the
bathrooms and build build the houses and
then these things just grow and all of a
sudden a hundred Man footprint is now a
2 000 person thing somebody's got to
operate the gym Somebody's gotta operate
the movie center and it just gets out of
control very quickly budget wise it gets
out of control yeah I mean you're
suddenly down and that's right and then
if you especially Look Around the World
in bases they say that you're also
you're also bringing cultural dynamics
that they don't want that when you're
off base you are influencing their
culture and you came here you started
with base it ended up as a village and
now you're influencing my culture and
that's where you get these deeper
resentments Okinawa I mean just look at
Okinawa the Marine Corps Base literally
they have hundreds of people that
protest outside the gate every day
because of exactly what is being
described the culture feels like it's
being influenced by the base and they
want it out but the Japanese are like no
it's too important to us it's funny what
Okinawa a lot of guys would go to
Okinawa and they'd come back married or
they would stay and become School
teachers like people they don't want to
leave Okinawa people lot of people come
back with a Japanese wife when they went
to Okinawa really what was it about
Okinawa that was so special
I mean I don't know if we can talk about
it okay
no but it's the example there you have
it and they're here and they're
influencing our culture and now they're
marrying our women and there's all these
things going can you guys just leave
please that's what all these protests
are Stu I don't know if it's a binary
thing so feel free to elaborate but you
know there's American interests Freedom
you know everything that we stand for
you know
uh capitalism democracy kind of putting
our footprint on the globe and then
there's corporate interest the military
industrial complex like it has nothing
to do with America and our interest it
has to do with making money and and you
know people just sucking at the teat of
the military where do you see the
military right now if those are the two
binary extremes I think the industrial
complex drives a lot of our conflicts
unfortunately I mean just take a look
General Mattis went from General
Dynamics to Secretary of Defense back to
General Dynamics our current Secretary
of Defense went from Raytheon to
Secretary of Defense General Dunford
right now is on Lockheed Martin I mean
all of them take these board member
positions on the oligopoly of Government
Contracting firms and the Government
Contracting firms hire them because it
Garners influence within the active
general population
and it incentivizes War
right and so it's a it's a problem and I
even put it in my book I think you can't
stop a general officer from getting out
and creating these
um
I don't know immoral unethical
connections but you can sure make him
choose between his retirement and that
board member position but I don't think
they should get both and so I I would if
I was a secretary of defense at least
have a cooling off period I mean that
just seems common sense like if you're
if you retire as a general for at least
five to ten years you shouldn't be
jumping on these boards but for whatever
reason I'm thinking in politics with
lobbyists right Pat you Pat you've gone
in on lobbyists and how you could just
jump from being a senator now you're a
lobbyist for a tobacco firm or whatever
it is you've you've have extreme uh
opinions on this one we've talked about
them many times when it comes down to a
lobbyist but by the way let me let me
ask this question so the nuclear bombs
have only been used twice in history in
Warfare right but they've been tested
over 2 000 times you got an article that
just came out here about China saying
China's vertical nuclear expansion is
real most concerning is the prc's modern
and grown nuclear Arsenal more precisely
the significant vertical expansion and
increase in the number of nuclear
warheads of this Arsenal in the hands of
such disabled destabilizing force it
needs to be confronted post-haste by
Public Accounts to PRC had approximately
240 nuclear heads in 2010 today it's at
350 by 2030 they're projecting to have
around 1 000 Beijing will continue the
largest ever nuclear force expansion and
Arsenal diversification in its history
Beijing it's not is not interested in
agreements that restrict its plans and
will not agree to negotiations that lock
in U.S or Russian advantages right okay
so if it's only been used twice it's
been tested two thousand times and
everybody is concerned about people
having nuclear bombs and everyone wants
to have them like what are you having it
for you know because if one starts and
it triggers and it's really a nuclear
Ward that happens worldwide what's going
to be left over if they go that
direction why is everybody so obsessed
with having nuclear bombs
it's the Assurance of mutual destruction
so I will say like there are countries
where you could look and they're they're
willingness to give up the nuclear bomb
resulted in us exploiting them I mean
look at Libya I mean that is a great
case study on you know pursuing nuclear
weapons we convince you to get rid of it
and then we topple you
um you know you could just keep going
down the list with that but I I when
looking at history feel like when a
country has nuclear power at least the
United States uh seems to respect them
more and I mean Pakistan is a great
example where if we really wanted to win
the war in Afghanistan at any point
Western Pakistan was the taliban's
United States of what United States use
Kuwait for to facilitate Logistics is
what the Taliban used in Pakistan but we
didn't want to go in there because there
were a nuclear power so
I think if I was a country that would be
something I would get because if you
don't have it and they do they're going
to treat you with less respect
purely about you know making sure you
have a little bit of Leverage and
protection that's an insurance policy
that's exactly it's something you may
never ever use but just the fact that
the other person knows you have it they
give you a little more respect right I
think the phrase that gets used and I
don't mean this in an ethically
derogatory way but there is a phrase out
there that says it's a Mexican standoff
which means that you're both kind of
stalemated I mean look at North Korea as
an example a tiny little Peninsula and
the
they're on the world stage because they
got nuclear bombs and it's literally
probably all they have or people
probably have to eat nuclear pieces of
bombs for and breakfast but people
forget what he's doing right his his
nuclear capabilities are actually you
know 1980 grade at best but what does he
keep testing the ability to deliver them
it keeps launching the interval inner
the the missiles that are unarmed so
what he's showing everybody is that he's
increasing his rocketry technology so
that he could deliver a bomb but his
actual nuclear capabilities are more
meager but it makes one crazy guy with
one dirty bomb and the ability to
deliver it into downtown Tokyo uh not
just a menace now he's got a chip at the
table
yep
so you put the story up Tyler North
Korea fires powerful missile using old
playbook in the new world the last time
Pyongyang launched a weapon was over
Japan in 2017 When Donald J Trump was
President Kim Young seemed intent on
escalating conflict into uh with uh
Washington and if you recall that's
exactly when Trump was like I would
release great fire and fury that whole
thing and people are like he's gonna
start World War Three and next thing you
know him and uh Kim Jong-un are
exchanging love letters it's probably
when Millie started collecting up the
nuclear launch codes and
and what's what's Wild is nothing
happened in four years that's what's
Wild nothing happened in four years
everybody was just kind of sitting there
saying let's wait for this guy this uh
this this guy to leave and then if we
want to do anything let's do it
afterwards boom he's gone next thing in
Afghanistan and all the other stuff
started not during his Reign but it
started right after him and they tried
to capitalize because maybe they were
concerned he was going to do something
about it he really the guy's insane he
really just wants a three movie deal and
a merchandising rights
but back to Trump you'd be the expert
here but
didn't he put together the agreement to
leave Afghanistan yeah we didn't abide
by anything in the Doha agreements
because the two abandoned abide by
anything at the door gotcha so everybody
wants to go back to Doha but we pulled
out a Doha okay so yeah I don't know he
he had a conditional agreement and they
did not meet the conditions of the
agreement and but correct what I'll also
point out though is that plan ended with
us holding on to Bagram Air Base okay so
when I hear President Biden you know
talking about the agreement that
President Trump got into after we left
Bagram it's just it frustrates me more
let me ask you one more on this topic
I don't think anyone would object to the
the nature of which we left Afghanistan
it was a mess we left 85 billion dollars
worth of hardware and you know now you
hear Iran and whoever's getting their
hands on it uh so no doubt that we could
have left a lot cleaner no doubt but the
concept of just leaving Afghanistan or
fundamentally leaving Afghanistan I
think a lot of Americans were just so
sick of the fact that we're still 20
years later how the [ __ ] are we still in
Afghanistan yeah right so can you
appreciate at least not the manner in
which we left but the fact that we at
least got out of there do you do you
agree that there was at least a major
appetite in America to get out of
Afghanistan yeah I mean if you go back
to my first video I said I'm not saying
we have to be in Afghanistan forever but
I am saying that I went on to what I was
saying I I personally believe that we
should have left a small footprint in
Bagram that's my position do I
understand why the American people were
over Afghanistan yes I think it's
short-sighted because you know just look
at the the al-Qaeda coming right back
into Afghanistan like you need some type
of base and presence in my opinion it's
a hotbed there's probably three or four
countries where you know terrorism grows
and Afghanistan is one of them bottom
line and so I think just from a national
security standpoint we need to have a
footprint we already owned that terrain
it made a lot of sense for me but
um do I acknowledge that the American
people were over Afghanistan yeah
absolutely and what what we when we
pulled out would we have 2 000 soldiers
in Afghanistan we started with 2500 on
one April and then we went down to 650.
so it was in minimal force and we we
were keeping peace in order that's right
that's right so that that exactly right
with 2500 troops we owned Afghanistan we
owned Afghanistan so the investment was
2500 troops and you own Afghanistan but
that was too much right and so that's I
you know and you just look I wish
somebody had the stat for how many
forces are in Europe right now there's
not a lot of terrorism being created in
Europe I mean there is some but not to
the point of Afghanistan and we probably
have you know 50 to 100 000 troops in
Europe right now right so it's just you
know do the math it seemed like a good
return on investment for me Stu this is
a pretty blunt question but um
you know there's a phrase that I think
you've used this Pat that in the Taliban
they said that well you guys have all
the watches but we have all the time
like
spend the next couple decades here buddy
spend 50 years here 100 years we're not
going anywhere okay but at the same time
you're talking about the United States
Military Marine Corps
number one
in the world versus a bunch of sandal
footed you know machete wielding gun
toting dudes how the hell did we not
just those are AKs okay how did we not
beat the [ __ ] out of them and just move
on like well how why was it even close
so I think we won most tactical
engagements now that doesn't that's not
all of them obviously but you also got
to keep in mind technology is one thing
but uh the the most lethal weapon is a
human mind and so if I grew up in
Afghanistan wearing a man dressed in
sandals but all I was told I didn't have
any TV all I was told about was the
Warriors that fought the Russians and I
was taught how to use an AK and I had my
buddies and that was like the only thing
in my world I don't care how much
technology you got I'm gonna bring some
lethal Force to bear and the people that
we had in our American propped up
government in Afghanistan were not the
real men the real men were the ones that
were you know grew up hearing stories
about fighting the Russians and they got
with their buddies and they got little
gangs together and fell within the
structure of the Taliban went over to
Pakistan got some more training and then
came over and fought and so you know I
don't the Taliban was never a terrorist
and that's I I talk about that in my
book they were the government they were
the conventional Force we displaced them
it was confusing because we were
fighting a global war on terrorism in
Afghanistan but that only strictly
applied to Al Qaeda which we cleaned up
very quickly so then we found ourselves
in a position where we were going
against the conventional Force the
Taliban and like you said how you
started this was they had time on their
side they were willing to wait us out
and so anyone that's willing to wait us
out if the American people get to a
point where like we don't want to be
there anymore then they're going to win
like you can't exterminate them right
you can keep winning tactical battles
but then it requires the American people
to say we're going to leave 2500 in
Bagram Air Base so we can continue to
pound them with air support when when
required
yeah you're you're really emphatic that
2500 troops in Bagram Air Forces and air
bases all we really needed I I think so
yeah I mean
you know crazier things have happened
but again we've been doing that for the
last five years
Stu when you were when you were deployed
and you were all over the place what was
the understanding or or maybe even the
interpretation you had on how different
Iran was dealing with Iran as a
government and Military than some of
these other countries in the Middle East
I mean everyone that I thought in Iraq
was uh Iranian mostly all the
electromagnetic force penetrators were
Iranian and so when you were in Iraq you
really you felt like you were fighting
Iran in a lot of ways all the things
that I studied originated from Iran and
that was my second war the first one was
when I was in uh Beirut and again
Hezbollah was a lot of Iranian influence
so I mean I've spent a lot of my time uh
dealing with proxy groups from Iran in
Iran's a major player in there and you
know the United States has gone in and
kind of destabilized everyone around
them you know Syria included in that and
now you've got Iran that kind of is just
standing there by itself as the the
regional player what's their strength
what's their weakness if you were to say
if you you're you're going to attack
them if you're gonna figure out a way to
help their people revolt against them
where democracy can come there you will
do it this way but this is the one area
their strength you cannot beat them in
this area I think I ran much like China
strength and weaknesses centralized
control and so you can play that against
them but it also can work to their
advantage where the United States
sometimes takes more of a deliberate
group of people coming to a consensus
where a government like Iran or China
can move much quicker because of the
autonomy and centralized control and so
the problem with centralized control is
if you move in a direction very quickly
and it's the wrong direction now you've
actually set yourself back much further
than you would in like a democratic
process so the the Democratic process is
more resilient because uh you know we
have a lot of voices that need to be
heard but at the same time it doesn't
move very quick and efficiently whereas
a centralized government can and so
that's what that's what I see when I
look at those two places now Iran I
don't see the the Communist Party of
China going anywhere but I don't think
the Iranian the alatola uh kamini I
don't see him lasting very long quite
honestly you know crazier things have
happened but the Iranian people are very
proud people and they're connected
technology-wise to the rest of the world
and they want to get you know the
Persians of the the day were probably
the the top of the food chain and they
haven't been there in a long time and so
I'd be surprised but crazier things have
happened but I see Iran going into a
revolution in the next 30 Years ish
before before the end of my time I
believe in the next 30 year-ish yeah
yeah I'm not saying it'll happen anytime
soon I got you I'm not saying it'll
happen but you can see the you can see
the cracks in the foundation and so this
these this might take a couple decades
but it'll happen and so I if I was a
United States President I would do
everything to stay out of my own way
because as I studied that model that
model is destined for implosion on its
own and the worst thing America can do
because oftentimes when you attack a
system you unify the system I mean you
saw in the United States in 911 you can
see it in Iraq like so if you attack the
system you unify the system and so I
would do everything I could not to unify
the Iranian system because that thing's
headed to implosion on its own if your
enemy is making a strategic mistake
don't interrupt them that's right
that's an old school Sun Tzu yeah very
interesting in the in the concept of uh
30 years Iran so China but on the flip
side you said China they're going to be
around for a while I agree yeah and I
think uh yeah China's continuing to get
stronger I've read a lot of things about
how it's all the shell game and they're
going to implode but I'm not sure I
agree with it I think um
just the strength of their population
and the you know
some of the shortcuts that they're able
to take right now that we don't take
based on
um
a set of morals whether that be right or
wrong
they're accelerating at a much faster
pace
How how Wild it is that they're they're
becoming allies because China signed a
400 billion dollar 25-year deal with
Iran and for them to unify that some
people say it makes it even tougher for
revolution to happen sooner because they
got the big guys on the other side
defending them backing them up I think
the alliance between Russia Iran and
China is an alliance of weakness so
mostly when you get into an alliance
with someone it's because you see the
world through the same eyes and you
stand for the same principles and values
that's not the case with Iran China and
Russia the reason they are aligned is
because they got no one else to align to
and so when I look at that Alliance are
they all powerhouses in their own right
and does that is that relevant yes but
at the same time you know China doesn't
want to be aligned to Iran they just
don't have anyone else they can align to
do you think it's a sign of weakness I
do I do absolutely do unpack that a
little bit more I think it's like it's
like if I'm on a a base level if I'm on
a playground and one kid gets all the
other kids to follow his lead and so I
try to make friends with like two other
kids that maybe are are not part of the
big group just because that's what's
left I mean China doesn't get to pick
its allies right now right Iran doesn't
get to pick its allies because of just
their behavior and so you know do they
add value by aligning to the other
outcasts sure but to me it's it's
symptomatic of not having a lot of
choices right it's almost like they
don't
they don't have any friends that's right
so it's like that's right you have no
friends you're gonna hang out with the
two other guys that have no friends like
exactly no one else wants to hang out
like you're you're breaking it down to a
playground that's exactly but quite
honestly even then like that might even
hurt you a little bit too because now
you've aligned yourself with Iran right
and we could talk about you know the
injustices of Iran uh for a while same
thing with with Russia so it doesn't
matter you know do they get some
strength and value by you know selling
arms or importing and exporting yes
absolutely they do but
on the long term is it helping them I'm
not convinced talking about you know
Pariah is on the world stage but here's
the question coming together if that's
the case then who who is in your opinion
the number one threat to you is if
you're saying it's a sign of weakness
between Russia China and Iran then who
is US's number one enemy outside of
internal no it is China no doubt no
doubt but I yeah I stand by that their
Alliance isn't it's something based on
what they had available right so is that
a strength of theirs I don't know
transition into a different topic if you
pull up that article I'm I'm you know
it's a topic we haven't reacted to and
had a conversation about yet uh you guys
obviously heard this Alex Jones ordered
to pay 965 million dollars uh for the
Sandy Hook uh lies until the political
radar uses movement from its ranks none
of this ends Senator Chris Murphy
um 965 and the way they came up with
this number is to say that he used Sandy
Hook to make a lot of money for himself
so the families are the judges ordering
him to pay 965 million dollars
this can go to anybody when you first
heard this number I mean I understood
some number was going to come out but
when you heard this number 965 what was
the initial reaction
that's a lot of money
so as well
that's a lot of money Tom what was your
reaction when you saw this I I think the
uh the verdict there and the penalty
phase is political grandstanding
um basically what they're saying is is
whoever you are you know
um and let's set it set Alex's sins
aside and what they're saying is whoever
you are if we don't like you and you
stand up to the scrutiny and you lose in
this forum we're gonna take everything
from you yeah that's the message that's
being played out here set aside the
things that Alex did well Alex didn't do
well the people that believe Alex the
people that don't
set aside all that this is a political
message that says we now have a
precedent and if we don't like you and
we can take you to the mat in court we
will take everything from you
I mean for me this comes down to
everything that's kind of been in the
political circles for the last five ten
years is what's the truth and what's
just fake news and this is as fake news
as it gets as far as Alex Jones and the
Sandy Hook lie and he's paying the
ultimate price for a massive massive
to be blunt like horrible shitty lie
um and I zero percent support Alex Jones
in this Arena on this with that being
said again not a fan of Alex Jones
what he did is disgusting but that
doesn't mean that other things he says
are now untrue right like you're gonna
have to kind of separate this horrible
lie that he's gonna have to pay the
price for forever billion dollars almost
and then he doesn't have other things he
has to say which may or may not be true
or false I don't know but this was a
very very bad lie and he's paying the
price for it now there's been a lot of
giant verdicts like this in history That
No One Believes that pennies are ever
going to be transferred you know yeah
I'm sure he doesn't have 965. it's a
completely different thing but OJ lost
the Civil the civil suit and you know
even pawning off his Heisman Trophy and
all now that's much different I mean a
crime was committed there he lost that
suit but he you know but the Goldman's
never got back tens of millions of
dollars for their legal fees and
everything else in the loss of their
daughter she knows sometimes when when
you go ahead you were gonna say
something I was going to say the random
note so Alex Jones and myself connection
uh we were just both on the best seller
list so when I I was uh number six uh
like USA Today in Wall Street Journal a
couple weeks back and I looked on it
Alex Jones had the I think number one
book number two book at that time he
needs to sell a billion copies yeah
what did the Bible's ever sold to pay
this in terms of pure money what happens
with does he ever gonna pay this is he
bankrupt does he how does how does this
how does this work follow the money
no idea first of all this is this is uh
uh I have some thoughts on this and this
is what my thoughts are you know how
sometimes
um somebody you hate which this is on a
list of a person that a lot of people
hate I mean this this guy's hated by the
people on the left many liberals cannot
stand the sky and they're glad he got
this and there are people that think
this wasn't enough there are some that
would like to see this guy go to jail
and spend time in jail for the rest of
his life many people can't stand this
guy having said that
there are a lot of people right now that
you know they're sending them what
they're thinking they're sitting there
saying
shoot I told a lot Eliza at CNN oh my
God what is this all about I mean
believe me I can't stand this guy but
dude a hunt 965 million
are you out of your mind like you know
when the metoo movement came out and in
Hollywood first person got the metoo
movement you all of a sudden saw a lot
of players a lot of big names are like
let me not attend the next party and
those pictures that were taken with me
at a party with this guy named you know
uh what's his name Epstein Epstein
whatever the guy's name is I want to
make sure I've never been with that guy
anywhere right so so the moral of the
story is the final one
how they came up with the number they're
claiming he made this amount of money
okay fine number two if the standard is
now that a person who's got opinions
lies you sue them well let me tell you
there's a there's a lot of people in
media that are about to get sued heavily
by a lot of families that were that were
affected by things like this and it
ain't gonna be pretty don't get me wrong
I'm not sitting here defending uh what
he said or what he didn't say that's not
my position my position is the following
Remington got sued last year
for 73 million dollars that they paid
you know for what for somebody else
using a Remington gun to kill somebody
they loved and the family got 73 million
dollars I don't know if you guys saw
this or not San Diego family settled for
73 million dollars with gun maker
Remington what did Remington do wrong
but here here's the other part if you go
a little bit deeper if you go go a
little lower so we can read the article
can you zoom in a little bit more so the
families are nine victims at San Diego
Tuesday have agreed to uh 73 million out
of settlement loss with the model maker
rifle used to kill the okay of a lawsuit
against the maker of the rifle used to
kill 20 first graders and six Educators
in 2012. okay the case was watched
closely by gun control Advocates and gun
rights supporters and manufacturers
because of its potential to provide a
roadmap for victims of other shootings
to sue firearm makers this has got
nothing to do with guns in my eyes this
has got nothing to do with guns and
mites can you do me a favor can you go
pull up how many people got killed by a
car accident last year
how many people died from a car accident
last year so doesn't this set the
precedent for somebody to be able to sue
a car maker to say my loved one
died by the car that you made so you
made but what do you mean I didn't drive
it I understand but you made this Ford
Focus you made this Tesla it's like it's
like wakusha or uh Wisconsin the guy
drove the Ford through the parade so now
you're making the case that you could go
sue for it you can go this guy forward
because yes the Explorer through the
parade that's what they wanted to avoid
here the reason Remington settles for 73
million dollars which I I can pretty
much I'm gonna go out on a guess here is
that their corporate Insurance paid that
right to get the settlement they say
listen we'll drop the suit and settle
but you're my insurance company you got
to pay the 73 they're like done here's
what we don't want we don't want the
legal precedent there's no precedent
here there's a precedent of settlement
but there's no legal binding precedent
do you see so there is no court case to
go back to as a as a hard legal
precedent that is a disaster if you're a
gun maker or a car maker or anybody that
uses something so Remington and I think
used insurance money here said let's get
this thing out of the headlines let's
finish this thing up and let's get out
what's the alternative if they don't say
they say we're not going to do it they
go all the way and they have a risk of a
of a crazy liberal jury you know handing
down a legal precedent
and then basically it becomes just like
those class action asbestos lawsuits
buckle up everybody was ever nearly you
see the asbestos ads that are on
everywhere on new shows from 6 a.m to 9
A.M I I don't know I don't once you have
a legal precedent that's what you get
you get class I get that but you know
what happened with Candace Owens
yesterday with a documentary that came
out did you hear about this that
happened that uh uh George Floyd's
family they're considering suing them
for the black lives matter documentary
that she made right there click on that
story write their trending news so
George Floyd's family feels betrayed by
Kanye West as they considered soon
rapper and Candace Owens after Kanye
West falsely claimed George Floyd died
from fentanyl uh uh and not an officer's
knee on his neck the family's lawyer
says by the end of the week we'll see
we'll have at least an idea of what
claims are valuable go a little lower go
a little lower so now uh an attorney
foreign
attorney Lee Merritt confirms the
Rolling Stone that the Fallout family is
considering Persona the legal case
against a rapper and say that he is also
looking into whether Ultra right-wing
Panda Candace owns could be held liable
as well since West has plucked a
debunked claim over her new daily wire
produced documentary the greatest liver
sold this is the whole BLM thing and
while Merit acknowledges that there's no
real grounds to pursue the defamation
claim on behalf of the deceased person
he says he the near one billion dollar
judgment that Sandy Hook parents there
you go Bingo that said new parents won
against Infowars Alex Jones spreading
conspiracies press presents a possible
pathway for legal recourse but not a not
a decision precedent I I understand that
but but Tom 965 73 million this could be
the new thing that people are going to
see this I agree go there and just get a
settlement they will most likely settle
with you because they don't want to drag
anything out
um my daily wire has the kind of a legal
liability insurance that Remington has
well and I also have or you said you
hope I doubt because the the member of
the United States the insurance is
always the pocket you go after well and
let's not forget that George Floyd had
enough fentanyl at a system to kill a
horse so they don't have a case here he
did he did have enough there were two
different autopsies done on George Floyd
one of which said he died of drug
overdose the second one said he died of
a knee on the neck and let's not forget
there was a nine minute tape of the knee
on the neck there was nine minutes
before that of George Floyd walking
around you could tell he was under the
influence of drugs you could tell all
these things so this these are this is
not an Apples to Apples comparison daily
wire could actually make a case here I
doubt they would lose this one but but I
understand what you're saying so Jones
provides the precedent for them to go
out all I'm saying is people are looking
at this and they're like
oh my God let me go get some money
there's free money there let me there's
let me go straight let me go through
this guy I agree this is becoming you
know a for for folks who I remember one
time I was at an event George Will was
speaking and George well this is at
Miramar Hotel Santa Monica 2000 and uh
I'll give you the date exact date March
20 something of 2009 and he gets up and
he says do you know why these hook you
know fishing hook companies you know how
they sell the hook and why they have to
put a warning sign on it now because a
parent sued one of the companies saying
you didn't put a sign under saying you
shouldn't swallow my kid swallowed it
and it hurt his belly so they sued the
company he says do you know why so many
parks in America are being shut down
because lawyers go sit there and watch a
kid fall and break their hands and
they're suing the city and they're
getting money out of it because cities
are settling so they're saying hey get
rid of the parks we're getting too many
of these losses so kids are now obesity
is going higher these types of lawyers
many times ruin a lot of different good
things so you you have to know like
going back to the same thing with
McDonald's Hot Coffee case I I'm not
comfortable with this man I'm not
comfortable with this I think a lot of
people are just so happy and they're
litigious and they're going to look at
going after a lot of different people
and many are going to settle because
they have the pockets but Alex Jones
does not have 965 million so I got a
point on this so in my ordeal I had some
media some Publications in my book that
ran not only you know we we hate Stuart
scheller or their opinions but like
factually untrue things right and so I
actually looked into a defamation suit
and I was told that it would be very
hard to prove because I was considered a
public figure and so once I make the
videos and I'm a public figure I go into
a different class of legality so when
you think of Sandman that that kid with
the Trump hat or you think of uh Kyle
Rittenhouse they're private citizens so
when they sue these people it's
different than if Stuart scheller were
to sue them and the the lawsuit I talked
to three different lawyers the lawsuit
all three of them brought up was Sarah
Palin suing some newspaper I can't
remember if it was the New York Times or
the Wall Street Journal but she sued
them because that paper alleged that she
had something to do with the school
shooting and she lost because she was
considered a public figure and so when
you're talking about New York Times yep
so when you're that that case right
there said a lot of precedent that like
if someone named Stuart scheller has a
YouTube video and it gets a million
views and then newspapers run factually
on true things the lawyer's advice to me
is you're probably not going to win
because you're a public figure go look
at Sarah Palin and so you've got to kind
of differentiate the cases here Sandy
Hook parents are considered individual
people they're not considered public
figures whereas Alex Jones is a public
figure so Alex Jones going to sue
someone because he got his feelings hurt
it would be a different level of
legality that he would have to get now
where I don't know where it stands
George Floyd you know is he a public
figure or is his family a public figure
I don't know the answer to that question
but there is a delineation there there's
also the media is given the uh the
malice defense you know if there's
absence of malice hey we don't we don't
hate Lieutenant former Lieutenant
Colonel Stuart scheller we were just
reporting the news yeah and the best
facts to the best of our ability that
was the news of the day and we were
reporting it and so that's referred to
as the absence of malice defense I mean
they they compared me to Hitler in one
of the and you know I served my country
for 17 years I mean some of the stuff
they said the and that's where the
malice line crosses so if when you make
metaphors that are inflammatory versus
just reporting it and then they hide
behind well you're a public figure
that's right but there is a line there
is a line there that they can't cross
even the media can't cross
even the media can't cross
what happened the last six years with
what a lot of these platforms media
companies they're talking about it's got
to be big enough it's got to be Stark
enough and you have to have enough
resources that you can take it all the
way here's a question here's a question
where when has a public figure won a
lawsuit against a news publication
like when's the last time that happened
I can't even think of one right and so I
maybe maybe a viewer can in the comments
section drop that but I would like to
know because quite honestly the media
has it doesn't necessarily always report
misinformation sometimes they just
report the information that they want
but when they say factually untrue
things like how are we holding them
accountable then that's where you know I
really started getting frustrated
through my ordeal because imagine a
marine officer that legally can't speak
in the media because he's under a gag
order and the media getting to say all
sorts of things some of them factually
untrue like there should be some type of
legal recourse so that when we're
talking 965 million you know what I mean
and then here I am and I'm not able to
sue anyone because I'm considered a
public figure
seems weird you say the last time that a
public figure Won Won a lawsuit against
a news publication first thing that
comes to mind is that whole Gawker Peter
Thiel Hulk Hogan
whatever that whole thing was didn't I
don't know was that a thing yep and um
it wasn't a lawsuit but
um
the Bush Administration took Dan Rather
to the map and he got fired
yeah
the president I think has a look we
don't have power though
no no correct correct but the point is
it's it happens but it's rare and if a
news media organization just says well
we're just reporting the news then they
are completely unassailable I mean
you're not going to be able to to to to
knock that over you know but when you've
got what Gawker did with Hogan if you're
willing to go long enough and pay for it
you can you can go get it done but it's
rare and it's hard
I don't know this this this is uh this
is uh it's gonna be the the Ripple
effects of this to see who's gonna Sue
who next will be very very interesting
to see I mean look how quickly they say
they're going after Kanye and Candace
Owens because of uh what happened here
with Alex Jones you're gonna see a lot
more of these but you're also going to
see writtenhouse going after you know a
whoopee what Whoopi said you're gonna
see a lot of it on both sides and uh
just like the metoo movement when it
first came out everybody was going after
everybody eventually everybody said guys
let's listen like I got you not
everything is this I don't know how far
wrong this is gonna go though where
they're gonna they're gonna be targeting
people lawyers will only take cases like
this on a sensational basis if there's a
pocket to if there's a pocket to settle
with they don't want to go all the way
with the court they want to go to a
pocket they settle with and that's and
that's where they're going uh we had a
presidential candidate
um oh I just blanked on his name North
Carolina John
who had the girlfriend and John Edwards
yeah he was he was a pi attorney that's
what he did before he got into politics
he was a pi attorney and he he talked
about it what was it the Esquire
interview he said listen it's there's
got to be Insurance you know
personal injury and and these Grand
claims yeah there has to be an insurance
company pocket to go after because that
typical company or person has no
resources to go after this is this is
another reason why if you're wise you
get into the insurance business
if you have wisdom listen get a life
insurance policy get an auto insurance
policy get a cell phone insurance policy
this is how insurance companies make
money believe it or not like
it just validates the importance of the
insurance industry and drive down any
American Highway and who do you see big
you know smiling face big rig accident
big rig accident they're going after the
oil company that that was their truck
they're going after Walmart they're
going after whoever commissioned or
owned that big rig truck that caused
your accident that's what all those
Billboards are on the freeway those
premiums okay so Town Hall article here
Obama tells Democrats to get over their
obsession with Trump the thing that I I
think sometimes we seem to make a
mistake on is his behavior can be so
outrageous and now folks who try to copy
him and his outrageous behavior are
getting a lot of attention Obama said
referring to Maga supporters and so we
join that game and we spent enormous
amount of time and energy resources
pointing out the lately the latest crazy
thing that he said or how rude or mean
of these Republican candidates behaved
that's probably not something that in
the minds of most voters overrides their
basic interests can I pay the rent what
are the gas price what are gas prices
how am I dealing with child Healthcare
Obama continued so it's what's what's
the reason why Obama is now saying this
today is it because midterms is less
than a few weeks away is it because you
know uh you know they're he's just kind
of watching people seeing how they're
losing control and he's worried how bad
things are going to be why do you think
he made the comments that he made can I
ask you a question yeah for you
um what do you think that the Biden
White House thought about these comments
no we don't want to talk about the
economy what are you doing
do you think the Biden White House and
the strategist appreciated the
ex-president saying not only that but
saying it when he say do you think maybe
deep down inside he wants Biden to break
his record you know what his record is
right most seats flipped 61 he's like
dude that's not a record I want to hold
it's like having the most strikeouts in
the season it's like look man I want you
to take that strikeout record away from
me all I'm looking for Biden is for you
to flip 62 okay to lose 62 and I'm happy
where I don't have to have that record
but why do you think you made the
comments that he made today three weeks
out two weeks out did he use Trump by
name did he actually did he say try I
don't know that's not Obama's style he
might allude to somebody I don't know if
he actually used Trump's name obviously
we know who he's referencing is when you
use terms like outrageous and crazy rude
and mean we know who he's talking about
uh however I don't know if he actually
addressed Trump what's your point though
but I do have a a I'm wondering if he
uses no he didn't he didn't use his name
so yeah that's check one number two I
kind of agree with Obama here about the
time and the energy
Jesus and I fell victim to this how much
time and energy you spent to following
up what the hell Trump said that day or
that week or that tweet
Jesus it took a lot of energy and time
for everybody whether you're defending
him and no that's not what he meant and
dear you're misinterpreting what he said
and good people on both like time and
energy and if you're one of the people
that were on the other side of the the
Maga you know side of things just the
the obsession that you paid attention to
all the ridiculous things that you lost
nights of sleep over this man and I know
there are not a ton of amazing things
that you can say about Biden but one of
those things is he's not making
ridiculous news that you can actually
move on with your life and spend your
time and energy on things that you can
control your own money your own
pocketbook your kitchen table issues
your family your health
so everything comes with a pro and a con
everything's binary but I do agree that
people spend a lot of time and energy
focusing on Trump
you have any thoughts on this sir I just
think Trump was the counter swing of
Obama so it's It's Always Rings false to
me when Obama is talking about Trump
because quite honestly I think Obama's
policies led to Trump in a lot of ways
so you know we're on the same page I
think he gave birth to Trump he did
that's simple yeah I think Bush gave
birth to a birth to Obama and I think
Obama gave birth to Trump I've got an
analogy doing some journaling and I was
thinking about this you know America's
political system in a lot of ways is
like you know a pendulum is one of those
things we take and the ball goes and
then it slowly stabilizes our the
American democracy was a pendulum that
started in the middle and is like slowly
slowing one way and then it goes back
the other way and like we're at a place
now where it's like violently swinging
from side to side and you know that is
the Obama Trump swing and in you know
back to Biden it's just uh I'm hoping we
can get some leadership that can
stabilize it and not have these violent
swings fully agree we've used that
pendulum analogy a ton of times and I
mean how do you go from Obama to Trump
to all the way back to Obama's number
two Biden just because
it's crazy
consulate pendulum swinging and I've
said it before I said it again I would
love whether it's a santis whether it's
any anyone else get to a somehow a 60
approval rating yeah every our last
presidents have been hovering below 50
for the better part of five ten years
now if not longer
um and
we need a UniFi or not I want to Tater I
want to do a story we got a surprise
couple guests that are going to join us
and zoom from London UK in a minute and
it's a very interesting guest that I'm
actually really curious to know why they
did what they did but I'll tell you what
that is here in a minute but prior to
going there so a story here average
American is losing thirty four thousand
dollars and everything else on Biden's
watch we have calculated over the past
20 months the rise in consumer prices
over wages means that the average family
in America has lost nearly six thousand
dollars in purchasing power that
negative returns don't even take account
of inflation don't doing so adds roughly
another 13 or so uh to these stock
losses inflation also hurts returns from
bonds which typically accounts to
between 20 to 40 percent of retirement
funds tied all together and we calculate
that uh since the start of this year
401K plans have suffered 2.1 trillion
dollars the average 401k plan has over
135 000 at the start of the year today
these assets have shrunk to 101 thousand
dollars wow in other words today the
average 401K is down thirty four
thousand dollars more than twenty five
percent in less than one year Tom
thoughts I I think this just underlines
how badly the middle class is getting
crushed and the media doesn't want to
talk about it certainly Administration
doesn't want to talk about it the
reality is the media is getting crushed
related to this B of A announced their
third quarter results on originations of
home equity
um mortgages and credit cards and home
equity lines went from like 2.5 billion
of new home equity lines Q2 to 2.4 so it
was down but it's interesting you know
what the average FICO score for the new
home equity lines was in Q3
792. what the average meaning only the
answer is only incredibly wealthy people
that have got the juice were able to get
the home equity line it gets worse the
did you guys just hear what Tom just did
you hear what Tom said or no now the
average person who got a HELOC their
average credit credit score was 792 in
Q3 and Q3 that's directly only people
with very good credit scores that's not
very good credit score that's Perfection
correct 796 again it gets worse also um
16.5 billion of new mortgage
originations happen in Q2 okay 8.7
happened in Q3 so it's almost 50 down on
mortgage originations here it comes
average FICO of the mortgage
originations this is B of A I double
checked it B of A announced us 768 was a
new mortgages in Q3 so the only people
buying our house are people that are way
up and able to afford it so I I think
you take those two pieces of information
that only the people with juice are able
to get helocs and new loans and you take
a look at all this the middle class is
getting crushed and if you just look far
enough you're seeing the true depth of
it people aren't buying new houses or
not able to get helocs and now they've
lost all this power and they've also
lost their retirement middle class are
getting crushed so badly
the true scope of it is not really
apparent
I don't know I think this article is a
little disingenuous and I'll tell you
why
um because I have a 401k all right and
you know I'm 41 years old I'm not
retiring anytime soon so let's say I
have a half a million dollars in my 401k
right now
and it goes down from 500 000 to 400
000. doesn't [ __ ]
[Music]
so it's almost
just like who cares however who it does
affect so this is why I'm saying it's a
little disingenuous are seniors we've
heard recent stories about
seniors or people that were going to
retire now have to extend their their
career for another three to five years
they have to plan on that and then
furthermore we're seeing further stories
that social security benefits are now
being extended what 8.2 percent more
than normal right so retirees if they
don't have a better plan in place then
they're the ones who are going to suffer
you know the article specifically
highlights the bond market you know it's
no secret that when you're young you
should have you know 80 in stocks 20
bonds or
um as you age 60 in stocks 40 bonds but
if if you're 75 years old and you don't
have 80 percent of your portfolio and
bonds what are you doing anyway here's a
challenge though go ahead the challenge
with that is you know I
as a person who's a financial advisor
for 20 plus years you know 20 years give
or take series 766 31 26 you take all
this stuff I've sold I can sell Futures
come out of these bonds socks stocks you
know options put call annuities life all
that stuff I cannot tell you how many
companies
who people have their 401ks with how few
times the average 401K holder
sits down to readjust and reallocate
where their monies are at yeah if I if
the average matter of fact if if a
person's listening right now and you
have a 401K with a company okay when is
the last time the 401K Specialist of
your company came in sat down with you
to tell you to reallocate it based on
your age where you're at with the
current economy when's the last time
that happened you know how often that
happens it rarely happens and if it
happens it's less than one percent of
the time so yeah the average person is
just sitting there saying man like
here's what happened the other day
somebody's got money in their 401K
pretty well known persons like hey Pat
man I haven't looked at my 401k for a
while can you just take a look at it
this is a person that's made real money
I'm like when's the last time you looked
at it not in a long time I'm like
seriously yeah and they're not young how
old are they they're late 50s early 60s
yeah they should be paying a close
attention to it but but it's not that
they should be you know it's the same
story with most people should get annual
physicals done most people should get
their teeth checked out most people what
most of us should do and what we do are
two different things most boomers are
not sitting there reallocating their
401ks on time most people reallocated
too late and they're gonna hit the you
know they're gonna they're gonna pay the
price for it so even though you're right
yeah for a guy like you're like dude I'm
not you're retiring for another 25 years
you know maybe you'll return three years
because your style is different but for
the average person in their late 30s
early 40s yeah it's gonna go for a while
you know people in their mid 50s late
50s early 60s they're not sitting there
reallocating the retirement well they're
being they're being hit by I'll add to
that because we talked about the
benefits of being the insurance industry
we've all been in it and um the the
number one thing how I made all my money
how is the concept of this annual review
or policy review okay yeah I mean you
talked about a physical hey go to the
doctor once a year go to the dentist
once a year just go get an annual review
the whole concept of you do it because
you haven't if you have insurance or if
you have a 401k get an annual review
yeah see what's going on yeah and some
advisor is going to tell you yeah bro
you're 65 years old you're 75 in stock
your asset allocation is out of whack
you gotta change that it's just an
annual review but a lot of people don't
even know about that content well you're
a good Agent though that you're doing
annual reviews correct most advisors
401K companies most of them are not they
sell agents they sell it and they never
come back a great agent who keeps
getting referrals they keep doing annual
reviews the client's not going to do an
animal but is that on the agent or is on
the client because we talk about
personal responses I'm going to say both
I'm gonna you're making your commission
do your job you're making the dentist
sends me the card and says your clinic
is in three months true do you know how
often I wake up in the morning thinking
about cleaning my teeth like when's the
last time you woke up saying you know
what yeah my teeth cleaning is in three
months I'm counting it down 90 days 89
days nobody freaking sits at you
somebody sends you that reminders I'm
gonna go to the doctor so okay anyways I
want to give a quick shout out to our
sponsors before we do so I want to tell
you two stories we're going to go
through right after this so stick around
we're going to talk about Kanye West
how he just bought parlor and we're
going to talk about what Bloomberg
yesterday said that we're a hundred
percent chance of going into recession
next year they didn't say 99.9 to leave
a little bit out they said a hundred
percent and I have a prediction on when
I think they're going to announce
recession but let's get into our sponsor
first do you know the fastest growing
crime in America today is it's identity
theft and there's a new victim every 14
seconds last year in 2021 50 plus
billion dollars was lost simply due to
identity theft for the first time in the
history of America
cyber crime in U.S exceeds robbery this
is the first time ever that this has
happened where cyber crime is at the top
and for many of us you know we looked at
a lot of different people on who uh uh
have as the sponsor on this Aura
monitors the dark web for your emails
passport Social Security numbers and
sets alert right away fast to your phone
and email when it comes to fraud every
second matters connect your credit card
and bank accounts and get notified of
changes up to four times faster than the
aura competitors their VPN allows you to
stay anonymous online by keeping your
browsing history and personal
information safe and encrypted and their
antivirus software blocks malware and
viruses before they infect your devices
for some of you who are not familiar
with Oren haven't taken advantage of it
yet on on the dark web many of you may
have your passwords on the dark web and
you don't even know it they do a test to
see if your passwords are in the dark
web one of our guys here who went out
there and actually tested it 44 of his
passwords were on the dark web where the
app average person can go find it if
you're sitting there again the whole
conversation today we talked about was
around insurance insurance
Aura is a form of an insurance protect
yourself and your assets uh and your uh
security from America's fastest growing
crime try Aura for free for two weeks
and see if any of you or your personal
or your family's personal information
has been compromised you can try a free
trial for 14 days at aura.com forward
slash pbd Aura a u r a.com forward slash
pbd Patrick David once again aura.com
forward slash pbd let's put the link
below in the chat as well as in the
description having said that Kanye West
to buy right wing social media platform
parlor owner says this is an Insider
story okay and this was all over social
yesterday Kanye West has entered into a
deal to bipolar right-wing social media
service that builds itself as a free
speech platform its owners said Monday
Parliament Technologies announced the
news saying that the deal would help
create an un uh cancelable ecosystem
where all voices are welcome West set in
a world where conservative opinions are
considered to be controversial we have
to make sure we have the right to freely
express ourselves
Parliament technology CEO George farmer
said that the company would be honored
to help him achieve his goals West has
recently locked out of his Twitter
account after he posted saying that he
would go death country on Jewish people
Tom when you heard this news what's the
first thing he thought about
um well Kanye needs a megaphone and no
one's given him one so he's gonna go buy
one for himself but I think he also does
believe in he says hey you know you
shouldn't be shut down for free speech
even though some of the things you've
said is like Kanye there's free speech
and then there's just crazy dumb
comments that just are just way over the
top but I think he's going out there
trying to establish a megaphone so that
people could be there people have to
remember what took parlor down wasn't
um
what took parlor down was a denial of
access to infrastructure the cert there
their server contracts were cut by
Amazon so I mean when these things go up
it's the The Playbook now is put
pressure on on the infrastructure side
and it just turns you off so you know
countdown you know can he buy this can
he have megaphone for himself but as
soon as he upset somebody they're going
to come after it and they're just going
to try to turn servers off because
that's a game or and take them out of
the App Store it's so easy you know you
have the Apple App Store Google Android
market those two and infrastructure are
up there does anybody know who owns
parlor like who George farmer is
do you know who he is he's Candice
Owen's husband ah
yeah he owns what
he's the he's the guy that makes a lot
more sense now parlor yeah yeah I mean
just like if you want to connect the
dots yeah that's Candace Jones husband
right there what do you think about this
you see you think this is I have a lot
of friends that are big fans of Kanye
West and so you know exactly like Tom
said I think Kanye West does some dumb
things but he's an entrepreneur uh he is
smart and I do appreciate someone that
pushes back on systems where it may not
be a popular opinion and he seems to do
that pretty regularly so you know some
ways I I sit back and say you know I
just watched him do an interview with uh
Tucker Carlson uh it was pretty good you
know I so he has moments where I think
of like quite honestly Brilliance but
then he has other moments where it's
just like man I'm not scratching my head
guys I'm so sorry Pat guys I apologize
Colonel I'm a veteran too so thanks for
your service I have a big announcement
and it's uh Happy Birthday New York's so
funny
you're so funny
happy birthday
[Music]
I really
thank you guys yes
hey dude the open end of the Bazooka
toward the enemy
just make a wish
let's go
[Applause]
[Music]
you guys are awesome
he was not happy with time
thank you babe love you Tyler
there were you
um
thanks guys
okay babe
thank you
Vinnie you're crazy
he came in at a time something actually
happened at the time it was uh it was
like right in the middle of uh us
talking about talking to Kanye yeah Pat
Uh I mean are we still in birthday mode
right now you can you can what happened
that door the average person shouldn't
close that door okay go for it well let
me just can I do one thing real quick I
I know I played dumb I didn't know what
today was your birthday yeah I actually
did know and I
oh really Adam's got a I got I got pbd a
gift right here okay there's gonna be
some humor involved there's also going
to be a nice this is actually something
you're very good at no well
um you know let me let me I I wrote
something down so let me get this out
um
what I got is a gift is uh down payment
okay you are now currently 44 years of
age you know I am currently 42. we have
a bet or an agreement that if I get
married by 44 I get married for free in
your backyard save that money I pay the
whole thing okay uh at the rate that I'm
going right now Life's good I I don't
see myself uh getting getting married
okay I'm probably gonna have to buy you
a suit sure because that's our end of
the agreement yes you never know what
could happen but uh in the spirit of
marriage and wife and kids
um I I did get you a down payment of
um it's not the full suit but there's
some items in there that you can wear
under the suit oh you're so amazing I
know you wear shirts under there yes
some Calvin you're like my dad you know
my dad bought me for my birthday this
morning is underwear yeah well I was
thinking about underwear that'd be a
little extreme I don't think you're
ready for that I don't know if we're
there yet but here's some shirts some
undershirts you had a good build up here
bow tie that you could wear potentially
oh okay not a little Papillon a little
Papillon uh you also have a black tie to
wear potentially with the suit Calvin
Klein I like it okay I went for
Salvatore Ferragamo but on Lincoln Road
apparently they don't have that that's a
handkerchief so this is a down payment
for the suit for the suit in two years
that I like they have to buy so with
that being said
um I have a
you're 44. it's a big deal
um so marriage I don't know where I'm at
with that but I I do respect the fact
that you're a family man and I think you
know as as as family men here kids is an
amazing thing so I think the example
that you've set with with with the kids
the four kids you have and Jen how you
treat Jen and Melva and your dad and and
how you open your house for everyone
that that's that's amazing and I think
everyone really truly appreciates that
um but more important than that you know
is the fact that you're a leader you're
our leader and um
you know Shia LaBeouf was one of your
favorite actors he says uh and he and he
was being interviewed by John Bernthal
great podcast by the way if we if
there's a ever a lot of a story of your
life movie John Bernthal could be the
guy he's the guy okay just putting that
out there into the uh to the atmosphere
but he says that you become a man you
become a leader when you're responsible
for other people and that's so powerful
because what makes a man does it you go
to war does that make you a man is that
a million dollars make you a man yeah uh
when you become responsible for other
people that makes you a man you're
responsible for a lot of people
everyone here at valuetainment PHP your
family so
um it's it Family Man amazing I don't
know if I'm gonna get there but the you
do a Aspire leadership and um I'm gonna
read you a quote I asked you this
morning if you know uh a rapper called
logic right logic if you're listening
huge fan massive fan white boys rapper
yeah so he has two songs and this will
be very quick uh the first song was
entitled 44 bars and the follow-up to
that was called 44 more and I figured
that very appropriate on your 44th
birthday to kind of cite some of the
lyrics of the song and how like true it
is to your life so without further Ado
uh in the first song logic 44 Bar says
it ain't all about the money in the
notoriety it's all about the people
making a difference in society but don't
get it twisted this life I'm living is
like a movie The Godfather the
goodfeller wielding and Uzi uh one with
the people got people wondering who is
he right and then he goes on and 44 more
and says I've done made 20 million
dollars right but I don't need a flex to
be acknowledged at this point it's
common knowledge all you haters have
been abolished you you and the club
throwing dollars but I'm saving mine so
my kids can go to college right then he
says oh Lord I'm a champion know the
name and now they know the Alias pbd
that's for sure uh Pat you gave him 44.
now here's the 44.
44. sick I love it I appreciate that of
course thank you shout out to Logic on
your 40th yes thank you thank you that's
awesome man appreciate you anyway so
yeah it's no underwear there but no my
dad my dad got me Puma Underwood you
know this makes it 25 years straight
that my dad for my birthday and
Christmas gets me underwear
he comes this morning he says you
already know what I got you I'm like
okay it's the typical Costco Kirkland
underwear whatever Costco sells but this
year was an upgrade what was it first
time in history of my life I got Puma
underwear from my dad I've never had
Puma underwear I think it is Puma above
Costco or is no Costco makes some
quality stuff no don't hate us
the one year he doesn't get you
underwear you're gonna be so bummed out
where's my underwear right though you're
absolutely I look forward to getting
underwear for many many more years to
come I'm hoping to get over the world
that's probably a deeper story there he
changed your diapers in Iran yeah right
and now he's living in your house in
your estate your complex here in Fort
Lauderdale so but back to the roots
don't forget I've always given you the
underwear it was so funny this morning
yesterday my sit my daughter's so funny
she's like uh she comes this morning she
says daddy don't tell anybody but uh we
have a surprise birthday cake and
presents for you downstairs but it's a
surprise birthday cake but don't tell
Mommy I told you
she's like we have a surprise waiting
for you downstairs everyone's waiting
and she's trying to hide it so Santa
cannot hide it I was gonna say we've
learned that Santa have to be trusted
that's not the surprise she's funny
she's funny how does it feel to be 44
people are shocked that you're only a
couple years older than me and my friend
like my friends are like what Pat is
only two years older than us like this
is insane like everything you've
accomplished your age what you've built
44 it's not exactly young but it's not
old at all how do you process being this
age now
I mean the only thing I woke up today
Jennifer gave me a a pamphlet that tells
you what happened in 1978 so I learned
some funny things so one
Transformers you know that one scene
where it's Shia LaBeouf and the actress
what's the actress that's not what Megan
Fox and they're in that yellow car and
she's trying to fix it yeah and the car
is not turning on she says I'm gonna
walk back so what's the song that plays
afterwards when the car turns on and
goes against the girl can remember the
song it's by a group called a band
called player from 19. maybe come back
right so Baby Come Back
1978 it showed the average salary who
won MVP who won the World Series the
Yankees won the World Series you know
all these different things about 197
number 44 was what Reggie Jackson you
have Jim Brown all these other guys but
to me it's just another number and you
know everybody else are we doing a
birthday this year I said we're not
doing one this year we're gonna do one
next year and then there's gonna be a
break and then we're gonna do the 51. 45
and the fifth weird one is going to be
uh uh it's gonna be
is going to be legit the 50th one we're
gonna have a good time I wear it on my
wrist but future looks bright Sprite PVD
it's just the beginning it's just the
beginning anyways okay he had no clue
what's going on today
what I just went from Afghanistan
but I do want to say this if you're able
to rewind at the end of the podcast and
go watch one of our home office
employees really is upset at Tom because
he just aimed it at his face it wasn't
like the record that way
I'm trying to get the confetti off my
gosh I watched it happen too he's like
yeah I've watched his face who wasn't
I'm actually really cute was it Robert
or who wasn't it that was it I don't
know Robert who was the time
never never attribute to malice that
which can be adequately explained well I
don't know I was trying to give you an
idea after what happened with Alex I'm
thinking like this is an opportunity for
you to file for now this is like one of
those it's like one of those Al Qaeda
fail videos for their the guys holding
the Bazooka the wrong way when he does
the test firing
and he takes out the back half of them
of their little training camp and then
they're all freaking out Stu has zero
glitter on them confetti we're good Pat
and I you're you're showered in confetti
you're gonna go home today and uh Kim's
gonna say can I ask you why you have so
much you have to explain you're gonna
say honey watch the podcast yeah watch
the podcast Where Have You Been hun yeah
okay I'm gonna make it rain in here yeah
so okay so let's go into we got 10 more
minutes to wrap up a couple stories
before we finish off uh I we okay so
let's go into the recession story if you
want to go into the Bloomberg one with
the last 10 minutes that we got so this
article this story comes out yesterday
and everyone's talking about a forecast
for U.S recession within a year hits 100
in blow to Biden and Bloomberg is part
of his camp that they went out of their
way trying to help fight and win
elections so this is not a good look
when you're seeing a number like this
Bloomberg economic sees near uh
certainty downturn will start typing and
conditions inflation hawkish fed way on
Outlook a hundred percent so if you can
zoom in here to see what kind of numbers
they have uh the latest recession
probability models by Bloom Economist
Anna Wong and Elisa Winger forecast a
higher recession probability across all
time frames with the 12-month estimate
of a downturn by October 2023 hitting
100 up from 65 from the for the
comparable period in the previous update
do they have any reasons how they came
out with this model Bloomberg surveys 40
42 economists predicts the probability
next home is another 50 earlier I mean
the numbers just don't look good no
matter where you look at the numbers
don't look good uh you're you're now
finally hearing
realtors in Texas is lower meaning
people are leaving the industry mortgage
is getting hit hardcore rates are going
to continue to go up Powell's saying
they're going to keep increasing rates
till they hit two percent inflation uh
next year you're gonna feel the
unemployment happening in 2023 my
prediction is with that part but I think
recession will be full on recession my
opinion is uh November 8th Wednesday of
this year okay is it November 8th or
November 9th what is November 7th is
midterm election yes
the election is going to be November 9th
Wednesday that's when they can announce
recession till then we're not in
recession right now according to the
experts in the U.S government right is
they're just gonna they're gonna change
the definition again it doesn't matter
how many times we hit we're already in a
recession but they're just going to
change the definition they're going to
go to Websters and have Webster's
reprint all new dictionaries
this is not a good look though did you
see the Gallup poll that came out did
you did you see the gallopol that came
out about uh uh uh gallup's been doing
this pull for the last eight years since
1940 okay and the whole poll is about a
better job handling problem you think
most important who Republicans Or
democrats do you trust can do do can do
a better job handling problems today and
this is Gallup the same Fox the same CNN
okay
48 said Republicans 37 percent said
Democrats today and here's the crazy
thing about this data since 1940 when
they started doing this poll
the widest margin they've ever had was
17 points in 1946
Truman was President this is right after
new you know 1945 1946 the American
people went towards Republicans over
Democrats 11 is the second largest since
1946 the highest since 1946 and again
the same Fox this is not New York Post
this is not Breitbart this is not Sienna
this is not MSNBC this is Gallup so the
American people are sitting there saying
listen Biden I'm sure your family loves
you but we kind of do for a different
leader to run this country so what are
your thoughts down when you hear this
Bloomberg saying 100
um I would say there's also 100 chance
that Michael Bloomberg is running for
president in 24 and he's basically you
know gonna let these kind of stories go
out and kind of help clear the decks and
he's sitting back there with I can see
Michael Bloomberg sitting there at the
scotch 61 flips I'm gonna make sure
there's 80. and then I'm running in 24
baby you really think he's running well
I mean you could connect the dots I'm
being kind of cynical and funny but I'm
connecting the dots but I'll go back to
something I said several podcasts ago
remember I said that I thought that you
know liberal media were kind of keeping
themselves on a leash but they were
slowly rolling now on on Biden and
they're just waiting for when the DNC
because it's exactly the process you
talked about for you know for individual
candidates for Congress that there's
also a date that when the DNC has the
Thunder money available to the National
presidential candidates and there'll
only be about four or six of them to get
access to that money and you know
Governor California desperately wants to
be put on the short list so we can get
access to it and I just think that what
what's happening with the media is some
of the liberal media is coming clean and
there's and they're truthfully reporting
things that are out there and it's not
favorable to the president but the
gloves are off and they were trying to
hold back a little bit help the
president but I think the gloves are off
in the form of hey we're just gonna say
what what it is and I the reason you can
say it's 100 chance of recession is
because I believe I think you believe
we're already there yeah take a look at
here look look at what's happened in
these home things so
Realtors have jobs I don't think so the
people that are in loan origination have
jobs I don't think so I think there's a
whole section of financial services
industry that's unemployed or
underemployed right now so when you take
a look at all that you're telling me
that we're not already in
the original accepted definition of a
recession right now and I think their
media is just coming out and saying it
they're coming out and saying it first
Obama says listen this woke stuff's not
working then Bloomberg says all in the
same week do you think there was a
meeting saying guys it's time for us the
voices of the democratic party to say
we're not with what Biden's doing so
they can come out and start their
endorsement this weekend next week so
some of the people that they're
endorsing their voice has a way to say
we don't support the walk decisions
that's been happening the last 24 months
or 18 months we need to go back to what
Dems used to do the timing of what
Bloomberg said Obama said all at the
same time it's kind of weird to me I I
agree with that I agree with you do you
think Obama's got friends that are in
Risky seats right now how
ugly things going to be on on midterms
GOP is going to win the house they're
not going to win the Senate and so
that's how it's going to play out by my
assessment and I think when they win the
house they're gonna pull some military
generals up the house will because
they'll have the ability to hold
committees and call some people make
some headlines But ultimately in terms
of legislation you know you still got
the president that can veto Senate will
still be a slim majority if not almost a
coin toss when you add you know people
that can vote against the party and so
really we're gonna have two years where
it's really going to come down to the 24
election and so that's my assessment of
it I you know you look at races like
Herschel Walker in Georgia where I think
a lot of people thought he was going to
win I'm not convinced he's going to win
I don't think Oz has a great chance in
Pennsylvania either I think that's
another sentence the weird one I know it
is a weird one what is that's a very
weird candidate uh so people want
authenticity right now so look at the
Democrat he's like this Philly guy with
this big goatee and then you got this
dorky white boy Dr Oz I mean just on the
surface without get like a deeper look
at you know their policies I can see why
people especially from the Pennsylvania
area would be veering toward
authenticity
um and then you know the Ohio race is
much tighter than we thought it would be
and then the New Hampshire race is one
where the Republicans are trying to
steal one
um and we'll see so those are really the
four key races in the Senate and and I
guess we'll see how it plays out
ultimately I think what you're saying is
candidates matter meaning like 100 you
know Herschel Walker you thought that
yeah
and he'd have a chance but Raphael
Warnock looks he's going to win the same
same as ours so if you use just generic
polling Like Pat referenced generic uh
Republicans have a quite an advantage I
think it went from three to ten percent
on Independence and that's on a New York
Times poll I want to give you one last
story here were you gonna go no no I'm
just saying that you know in the Senate
I agree with you because if you're going
to look at the actual candidates forget
about generic polling that's right
you're gonna go with the person who's a
little more authentic but by the way
that's a very weirdly authentic guy
though I mean I don't know if you've
watched him interviewing no so yeah my
caveat is I don't know anything about
the about him but I'm just saying on the
surface I think what the appeal is is
that he's a Philly guy that relates to
you but I don't know anything about him
very very weird situation so last story
here before we wrap up uh Nike
co-founder Phil Knight declares war on
Democrats in Oregon
uh Phil Knight said he will do anything
to block Democrats from keeping their
hold on Oregon's Governor's seat uh
Knight 84 has poured cash into the
campaigns of Democrats Tina kotec
opponents and Governor's race he helped
to kick-start a campaign for Betsy
Johnson a former Democrat running as an
independent who is serving as a major
supporter to kotec Johnson's candidacy
is given Republican Christine Drazen the
opportunity she needs in a liberal
electorate no longer confident in the
State uh recent far left policies won
the political uh cartoons after our
legislative uh session had a person
snorting cocaine out of a mountain of
White Knight said Saturday it said which
of these is illegal in Oregon and the
answer was the plastic straw yeah I'll
tell you one thing do you remember a
couple years ago Oregon legalized or
decriminalized all drugs all drugs
that's the one state in the country
where
whatever you want have at it and
ironically what's illegal not the pound
of cocaine the plastic straw that you
can do the cocaine from it's very ironic
I think I think this is sort of a sign
of the times if this is like a canary in
the coal mine very weird you know Phil
Knight Oregon Nike they're not exactly
the most conservative people or conserve
a company Colin Kaepernick they were
behind Colin Kaepernick but it just goes
to show how far left Oregon has gone and
they're in need of an over correction
yeah I don't think people understand
just how rough the the general citizens
of Portland had after all of that stuff
settled out Chas yeah that City or
whatever yeah though the whole thing I
mean it was just terrible and you get
citizens in Oregon now the reason this
is close isn't because of Phil's money
it's close because there's a lot of
citizens out there and Phil's money and
the citizens who are being pulled
they're like this is the wrong direction
this one the violent pendulum you're
talking to and remember this is also
Oregon the state that when a large whale
was beached and rotting the solution was
to blow it up with dynamite so you have
to remember the legacy of Oregon if
anybody wants to go look on on the
Oregon whale that the highway department
blew up with dynamite
and this is ladies and gentlemen this is
your Oregon you get what you vote for
and I mean you gotta go back and vote
for something else
to wrap it up still you know your book
that just came out a month ago crisis of
command how we lost trust and confidence
in America's generals and politicians
what can you tell the audience that uh
that in this book that maybe we didn't
talk about today yeah I appreciate it so
I wrote the book for the American people
I think since the all-volunteer force
following Vietnam the American people
have been conditioned to thank military
members but they may not necessarily
understand the systemic problems that
exist in the military and so I wrote The
Shed light for a normal American because
you know we've been talking about voting
here in the last segment and in politics
a lot of Americans go and vote based on
like what's right in front of their face
whether it's inflation you know prices
at the pump jobs and they don't think
about military and foreign diplomacy a
lot but quite often military and foreign
diplomacy affects everything like
inflation jobs you know all these things
gas at the pump and so I really think
it's important for Americans to
understand how we can get the United
States military back on track which will
allowing all the things we were talking
about when we started the podcast about
who the global players were and are or
will be in the future I think it's
incumbent on the American people to make
some of the changes and I and I lay out
ways that they can do that and so the
book goes through the
first 17 years of my career in the first
half of the book where I outlined the
macro problems and then it goes into
when I posted that video the micro story
of what happened to me the real raw
portion of it that further reinforces
the macro trends that I described so I
think people enjoy it if you haven't yet
ordered it the USA Today bestseller Wall
Street Journal bestseller we're going to
put the link below in description and
chat go ahead and if you support Stuart
and what he's doing after giving 17
years of his life to the Marine Corps
going out there you know providing
freedom for the rest of Americans while
he's out there serving you can support
him by ordering his book we'll put the
link below as well brother thanks for
coming out this was actually very
interesting you're you're you know
sometimes we bring guests they go three
four levels deep on a topic you went
really really deep on certain Topics in
regards to military that was very
helpful I hope the audience enjoyed it
as much as I did gank happy birthday
guys thank you thank you thank you thank
you everybody are we back Thursday we're
not doing pop
on Thursday that's going to be
interesting okay sounds good potential
Hall of Famer MLP he belongs in it the
only reason he's not in there you know
Reggie Jackson said Kurt Schilling thank
you to your freedom of speech the reason
why you're not in the hallway we'll talk
about that on Thursday take care
everybody bye-bye bye-bye